Argentina were fired into the World Cup  final tonight by who else Lionel Messi  there was no tense penalty shootout in  their semi-final with Croatia only an  emphatic win our Sports correspondent  Rob Paris is in Qatar tonight Rob  we'll have all the major trophies to  being won by Lionel Messi the World Cup  is the last major prize to elude him and  when this world cup began with a shock  defeat for Argentina against Saudi  Arabia it seemed that Messi's Destiny  might not be fulfilled here in Qatar but  in the last few minutes after beating  Croatia Messi says that the acid test of  the squad was fulfilled and they've  shown their strength here as we saw the  mesmerizing magnificence of Messi in  front of almost 90 000 fans